uh a bunch of people have asked me to
comment
about an article written by cnn's brian
stelter yesterday
and um stelter is not a guy that i
particularly follow
um
but sometimes he says interesting things
and i think that this is really an
interesting article
the idea here of what brian stelter is
arguing is that these new unhinged
appearances and interviews and rallies
that donald trump is doing are a sign of
some kind of big storm brewing again
that there's multiple factors here and
that there could be some kind of perfect
storm in a sense
between trump and trump's followers in
the republican party and other just
opportunists in the republican party uh
let's take a look at a little bit of the
article uh stelter writes i watched
donald trump's entire interview with one
american news propagandist dan ball
and the quote that stood out the most is
our country will not survive this trump
was in the middle of a fact-free rant
about vicious democrats cheating on
elections when he said they're
destroying our country our country will
not survive this our country will not
survive then he sniffed and shifted to
immigration saying look where they're
coming from clearly mimicking the great
replacement theory
that tucker carlson has been mainlining
into homes across the country
these are all signs of the gathering
storm trump's incessant lies about the
last election biden didn't get 81
million votes there's no way pose
obvious threats to future elections the
so-called stop the steel movement is
racing forward ignoring the arizona
audit humiliation
most of us can feel the instability in
the air the same way a forecaster can
feel a storm coming on news outlets need
to be providing storm warnings but some
are ignoring the threat
that's what okay so he talks about his
opening essay uh
he points it so so far this is pretty
good
stelter also points out that the
right-wing media with few exceptions is
a safe space for the big lie
that's according to timothy snyder
that's absolutely true there has not
been a real concerted effort other than
the minimum needed to avoid legal
problems to say
biden won
that's it all of this other stuff is not
true stuff about voting machines stuff
about
bamboo fibers and barbecue sauces and
various dressings on on ballots and the
ballads being cured or sauteed or smoked
you know i'm exaggerating but none of
this stuff is even there's no evidence
for any of this stuff
um
going on to talk about does brian
stelter
liz cheney says
many of her colleagues in the republican
party privately agree with her privately
agree with her that this election lie
stuff just looks very bad for
republicans the idea being these
republicans are
going along with this stuff even though
they don't believe it at all
and then the big picture according to
stelter is that democracy is in the
midst of a grave recession and points to
hungary poland and venezuela countries
that are no longer really democratic
although they purportedly hold elections
so
i think that there's there's a
you know
i don't find stelter's writing to be
particularly compelling and i don't find
his commentaries to be particularly
interesting but i do think that he's
pointing to some broader truth that
can't be denied at least as a
possibility
trump himself is a narcissist
to the absolute highest degree
the election loss hurt him in a way
that a non-narcissist can barely
understand i've been reading about it to
try to understand how trump gets to this
point where he does the things he's been
doing but it's hard for non-narcissists
to really understand what's going on in
trump's brain
and in addition the idea of people not
paying attention to trump
is very very uh scary to him as a
narcissist that's trump
on the follower side you have
really low information radicalized
trumpists that are in a sense enamored
with trump as this narcissistic
egomaniac
i don't think we're exaggerating if we
say
many of them are willing to die would be
willing to die for trump would be
uh not that that's going to be a
situation that presents itself for
99.999 of them although i mean you know
look at january 6th it's not it's not
merely hyperbolic or theoretical to say
a trumpus might die for trump in some
sense
so you put all of this together and then
you combine it with a republican party
that even if we grant
adam kinzinger has said it liz cheney
has said it a couple of them have said
privately
almost nobody agrees with this stuff
like kinzinger i think said there's a
couple people in my mind i'm thinking he
was talking about marjorie taylor green
or whoever else
if they are right
what that means is it's not that we say
well at least the republican party is
sane because behind the scenes they
don't believe the stuff no no no no
they're the worst class of political
opportunists we can imagine because
behind the scenes
they don't believe it and yet they allow
all of this stuff to continue and in
some cases they actually signal boost it
and help it continue
that combination narcissistic trump
uh enamored
egomaniac low information trump
supporters who will do whatever he says
and fall for whatever and then a
republican party that whatever they
believe privately isn't getting in the
way of what donald trump is doing
that is a very disturbing situation and
you could
see circumstances in which if they do
well in 22 if they take the house
they're almost certainly impeaching joe
biden without question it won't he won't
get convicted in the senate but almost
certainly and it may be the exact boost
to what we are hoping is a dying
movement in trumpism doing well in 22
could be the exact type of boost that
will make 23 to 25 the pure that that
legislative session
crazier than even what was going on
under obama when they 63 what was it 64
63 times voted
to uh eliminate obamacare when they had
the house and obama was president we
said what a waste of time this is crazy
that will be nothing compared to what we
will see from january of 23 to january
of 25
if they take the house partially because
of what they'll do but partially because
of the energy boost it will give to
people like trump and others who will be
thinking about 2024. so stelter's pretty
spot on here i don't know that i would
tell the story the way he tells it i
think i would look at maybe some other
uh indicators
but there very well may be a storm
brewing and these are the exact worst
people that we would want
running the weather satellites so to
speak when that storm is brewing agree
with me disagree with me let me know you
can find me on twitter at deepakman
science has shown us that lowering your
body temperature at night helps you
sleep i can't sleep in a hot room that's
why i love our sponsor chilly sleep
which makes customizable climate
controlled sleep solutions to sleep
better their flagship products are the
uhler sleep system and the cube sleep
system which is what i have both are
hydro powered temperature controlled
luxury mattress pads you can make them
as cold as 55 degrees fahrenheit if you
wanted you could go as hot as 115
degrees
i like the cooler option i keep mine at
60 degrees and it gives me a great cool
night of sleep no feeling hot no more
sweating i'm falling asleep faster and
it pairs perfectly with chili sleeps
weighted chili blanket which keeps you
cold on top too they'll give you 20 off
everything when you go to chilisleep.com
pacman the link is right underneath this
video